and come to clay county
here where i'm at now manchester
kentucky ain't no jobs
nothing and i told the judge that i said
your honor
i said i wouldn't be this way if you
have something for me to do
and you know it's true that's what's
wrong with these kids today here in clay
county
there's nothing for them to do there's
no what kind of
uh recreation there's no swimming pool
there's no pool room what is gambling
but there's nothing there's no kind of
no movies just a little downtown
all right jerry lee julie where'd you
grow up where are you from originally
i'm from manchester kentucky and tell me
about your
family you had both your parents growing
up yes
poster childhood they're pretty rough
really really well there was a lot of
verbal abuse
and i guess abuse that where you
see your parents hitting with one
another's knife stabbings
and uh how bad the uh
the violence good it got really bad i
guess it got so bad my god dude
my mom got sick i think that's where
he took her at that age because my dad
was stabbed it was low now i started
sticking her back of her head
when she was trying to take up burrell's
kids and see your dad
he was really bad jealous just like see
your dad killed your
no my real mom died in natural causes
your dad killed your stepmom
yes after she died after my real mom
died
he got remarried to a girl to a woman
that he
went to school with and then
11 years till january 5th
of 2000 and
five january 1st 2005 when it happened
at six o'clock in the morning i was
going to work
i lived in northern county i was taking
my wife to work
she ran out the door saying they thought
it was me but it was my dad
for murder he was held up in the house
i thought he killed himself but he was
in there with my mom
he kept her two days when he passed out
i don't see how he could donate and
but i think what he did he just had so
much you know in his
mind where he didn't get help like i
want i want help
because i could turn out really bad
and i don't want to go that way i'm
going to choose a good path if i can
but daddy he was i think he's what
changed me
made me who i am today because if people
had done things
all he did was to do good in life
because it gets harder
and it does it's true it's harder
so how far did you go in school to the
eighth eighth grade
i went into high school but they told me
where
that's your grade you graduate in
when i graduated with unsigned diploma i
was a
matter of fact just right over there you
could see horse creek
and uh so drugs are very prevalent yes
is that worse you play county kentucky
what did you get started with that i got
started on drugs
i probably
i'm gonna say seven seven years old is
marijuana
and actually this boy was daddy out here
and
my uncle pete the one one on guy started
marijuana
when i was young and then you got into
harder drugs at what age
yes it uh
15 i think or you know 17
pain pills pain pills are a big thing
out here
i didn't say well i'm gonna take it back
i was getting a bottle of xanax's me 14
years old
i went to a doctor and told him that i
needed something but the baby made me
nervous
i was going on so you had a child at
what age
15 15. i don't even know hey
same as jack charles you know that guy
in that truck out there
yeah the small difference in him
and how old was your was it was your
wife or the mother of the child
that what now the mother of your child
was how old
she was uh i say 16
i was 15. okay and you guys got married
yeah
and how many children do you have i got
four
four and you were around to raise them
okay what did you raise your kids no i i
did two
to where i couldn't tried to raise my
kids
i was expected to like a regular parent
really rest your life but
i didn't get to do it all because my
women i had with surround ones
i tried to raise them in the car
because when we split up i didn't know
what to take them to
i would stay in a car for a week
week at time you know and take and i
think we'd go to a lake in corbin and
bath
wash out me my son but he thought was
camping but we didn't he didn't know
what i was doing
he didn't know we didn't have a home and
him and her little dog
now he's 19 years old he's asking me but
he do
my son he knows when i'm sad
because he seen me hear him not too long
ago around one o'clock at night and
crying up here at mike's pit stop
arguing with the lady that with now
he didn't think i i kept things hidden
from him
probably most happy but he caught me
that night
you get depressed sometimes yeah off
time now
it hurts to think you know if
why did why did it happen
why did my daddy do that why didn't he
do things different
but he i see you know there ain't no
jobs here where i'm at
he had to work tonight watchman he'd
done it for 21 years i think
i just seen him when i come in from
school when i was getting up early
mornings
uh he was getting us up
around six o'clock 6 30 i wouldn't have
no time to even speak with my i don't
even know my dad i left
they told me 15 years old then
then my mom died what drugs have you
done
i've done made everything they have done
here
i've done a lawyer said
that i guess it'd be a lower hydrocodone
morphine and my
favorite drug was cocaine
my favorite one and i've done everything
that
that you know about except uh
be your alcohol and i just started
drinking it
i told here on the last of 2012.
and i just got out of prison
because i knew my home wasn't the same i
could tell
that's when i had a son come see me in
louisville i stayed in a high play house
that's what helped me that place it
saved my life save
me probably other people because i took
it serious
because i knew if i didn't go to this
place
or try to get help i'd never get it
but the guy that had run the place he
was a colored man his name was joel
to me it's more on the second uh court
but he said jerry used to quiet i didn't
even know he was here
because i went up to him last week of my
time there at that place
and told him thank him for for the
classes and helping me realize
but he's telling you i should have
spoken up you know
same thing my dad said before or dad
you need to speak up some people not
gonna know you're here so now i do
just like today you insured me i argue
i'll argue with you i fight with you if
a lot of people thinks i lie i mean when
i get mad like that
that i did it but i'm just trying to i
don't know how
what reason uh i took it now i guess i
take in the wrong mold
or something like a real defensive mode
like that
up there i don't know i said it wrong to
her but i did
it just hurt me and your prison time has
been for what kind of stuff
for escapes escaped to escape charges
or duis possession
salt charges
and uh ftas
and mercury's how far have you traveled
around the country
have you been anywhere as far as i've
been in jackson mississippi
in uh georgia
that's in cincinnati that's
as far as i've been
i never traveled that's someone my
that's my one of my main goals though
travel how old you 46 46
so it's difficult for a young man to
find work here in clay county right
yes it is you've done pretty good you've
had some jobs no i've never had a job
before my life here
i've always tried to yeah i mean you've
had you've had to travel before but
you made the effort to get work yeah it
was hard
but to stay here in clay county as
you've chosen to do makes your life very
difficult
right really really really hard
because you're surrounded by what drugs
drugs
just i'm surrounded by
and you choose to stay here for what
reason you think
and i'm gonna say what i'm choosing to
stay here because my little brother
that's what i was telling my third thing
you answered that question i'm leaving
here since if i can
i gotta get some kind of support to do
it though
is our drug still a problem for you
today
yeah what are you using today i use
suboxone
in the rotten and i use marijuana
sometimes to sleep
but the suboxone i think is no different
from any other drug it's the drug
it just takes the place of another drug
but it will help you
if you use it right and
it is prescribed it took me years to get
it prescribed i spent every time i had
to get in that drug
having to buy it off the street you know
i finally got me a doctor now it's my
chainsaw
if i could get me another job i could
save my money
i had to spend it on my what would you
call it my habit every day
i got picked cans up when i moved to
clay county
when i left somerset i was working
and coming to clay county here where i'm
at now manchester
kentucky ain't no jobs nothing
and i told the judge that i said your
honor i said i wouldn't be this way if
you
have something for me to do and you know
it's true
that's what's wrong with these kids
today here in clay county there's
nothing for them to do
there's no what kind of uh recreation
there's no swimming pool there's no pool
room
what is gambling but there's nothing
there's no kind of no movies
this little dead town used to be
i'm here lively back then had a little
drive in now they shut it down
do you have any friends here they're all
dead
this is what i got mine
i had friends i got they did have it
that's why i wasn't going to tell you
when we go in if i went with them
they chose i guess not working things
and that's what saved me i had a job
a few times if i'd went with those
friends
i wouldn't be here today talking
because the same car the same
boys i knew went to school with these
boys took my best friend out and shot
him
in the back killed him they wanted me to
go with him
if i'd went the next day
that wouldn't be i've been killed they
found me shocked
they came after me i could have i think
i was
17 or 18 years old now this boy got out
here a few
years ago my last year year last year
or two years ago i'm going to say you've
done a lot since 20 years
20 years the same age i am boy it is now
you know
20 25 years i couldn't do that now
too old what are your children doing
what do they do what are they doing how
old are they now i got
my oldest child i think is 29
and my oldest girl and someone will say
20.
my oldest boy is 19 and my youngest girl
is i think cleveland
and this is you're staying here in clay
county and um
two of them are two are gone in other
counties
i got a girl who lives in corbyn with a
she's in a foster home
and my boy is getting ready to be a
daddy and i'm going to be able to help
all that's one thing it's made me i
gotta get myself straightened out
because i won't be an example
i want to be able to tell them to try to
guide them in their own way
in the right way you know take that
wrong path don't want to do nothing like
i am
you still talk to your kids yeah but
that is just when i think when they
wanting something money
or something or they're at the you know
i
do talk to my kids they are but i got
i try to talk to my oldest boys when
it's getting revealed a daddy he's never
have
he's the one that seemed like his family
he said you want to be a killer like his
pawpaw his name is christopher
he breaks my heart when he just says
that he says what
he wants to be a killer a killer like
your dad
like his papa my dad and
but i think they got him some kind of
help and he's
he straightened it he don't care
hope not but he's he gave him a job
but he quit school
uh i don't know just
let's see it's happening about me two
months ago i
i got a way of calling him but i used
facebook and i was trying to explain to
him i felt good because he's gonna be a
dad
i was totally immersed in i don't they
going to school
while they can or homebound don't
i just told my story i told my mother
some of it but his girlfriend took it
the wrong way
and she just thinks i'm i was telling
she took it the wrong way i guess how i
said it not to be like i was i
i chose the wrong path i chose
laura said stuff like that she thought i
stood it now but i was trying to tell my
story
like i was here
and we got into it and she blocked me
but he told me he said dad just she just
took it the wrong way
but what i was trying to do is use
myself an example and describe how i did
it
but she thought i was talking about it's
the future now i guess
but i was talking about the past
that it destroyed my life i chose the
wrong road i chose to hung out
with your own friends and i had caused
me to be that way
that i am now
and what's your biggest regret
now to finish in school if i'd win i've
lost
i could have had so many good jobs if i
would have finished school
my education the kind of work i do now
i always wanted to be like electrician
or
or or a lineman a good lineman is
is just like the best thing coal mine
had paid the top dollar
it was dangerous was work for the
electric company
but you had to have a high school
diploma and i couldn't get it
if i'd finished school i've been set
right now
do you regret not being a better role
model for your kids yes
i do because with my dad been he'd been
there for me
and been more provided
or you know uh a role model for me i
didn't see my dad anybody to be a role
model
i had to learn it all on my own every
day every step
it was so hard every mistake i made
i paid for it but that next week when i
started back in i wasn't going to go
back and do that again
but i got further and further around 46
when i'm almost 50 years old that's hard
to believe and the friends
all my friends didn't think that way he
chose the wrong path
i don't have a friend out there ever
might be a few of my cyber
they moved away or something but never
clay county
ain't nobody that i have i just wished i
went farther in school and done right
to regret it how much do you credit your
environment
versus your family for the uh
for the path your life has taken
if it would change how would
you think it's the the family that you
had around you the role models or
is it the fact that you grew up in here
in clay county
i think you said about women a lot of my
doctors told me it's the environment
i'm in it's what they tell me that i
could take the drug that i take now
to help me his environment the people
i'm around
and where i'll go was there they snuck
but violence
and where you go i don't have no words
to run
or hide no more so i got to take this
i got to take this to heart and learn
and do it fast
because time going it's going on you
can't stop it
every mistake i made i don't wanna do it
no more it's hard i don't want to go to
jail
because i i prayed right now that my i
feel
strange but i feel like something's
wrong
and i'll probably be in jail next week
because this girl she's crazy in hell
over me
said she never had nobody like me but
she shouldn't
be so jealous you know trust if you
don't have trust you won't know
you don't have nothing man honest i'm
honest to her
i've been married three times and every
i'd give each one of them women
something very special
a baby and they took it away from me
i'll split herself apart from me and
being a dad to them
something that that was my lifeline to
for me to do good because i wanted
to do for them kids that i wanted when i
was growing up because
i see these kids in school how'd they
get to
have a mustang or that and you know
where
i had a new home i wanted to be able to
tell them how to do it and
what it takes to get that goal you got
to
have the will on the heart to do it and
everybody help me
but it's been bad
i can go back in time i i don't know i
can change the subject go back what
really hurt me a lot
i got i don't play football best
football player here
in clay county i won the championship
really school
and then like i could get in trouble and
not even have to worry about it i set
principles out my life now change school
and the bus driver took me home
i said it's happened to a lot of kids i
ain't ashamed to say it but it's hurt me
you know my daddy verbally hurt me
bad and abusive i guess with his
but gumbels but to my bus driver
and there's probably all the little kids
just not spoke up and said
about it you know my
i guess reason my mom and daddy let me
go they trusted that bus driver
but i told my mom i didn't tell my daddy
she knew but she was afraid to tell him
pretty [ __ ] what happened with the bus
driver
he he took me home with him let me ride
little horses little ponies he had race
horses
he then it came in time
and laid down wanted me getting the bed
with him and he touched me and so
you know i was uh
i was 13 and like i said
14 15 i was marrying and i didn't say
that when i go work i think of that
people knew i was ashamed of myself i'd
get so mad i worked so hard
i worked harder he hurt me
he broke he i thought of it every day
every day about my life pretty much
that's how i do second day i had taylor
i'm ashamed i mean i'm not ashamed
i should have spoken a long time ago now
it's like what he's done
you know i didn't get asked for help too
late till it's too late
it's not too late oh it's not it's never
too late
because i say so much i want to say to
every anybody or everybody
all right julie thank you very much
you